the age of monetary policy is over so
that miracle russian resources chinese
labor credit cycle of 40 years
that provided a tailwind for the equity
markets the boomer demographics peter
zeonta is a total demographic account
and when your demographics are favorable
which they were for the last 40 years
then you've got this this massive
workforce just showing up and
cranking out daily right and and
you have a relatively small percentage
of the population who were consumers and
only consumers
we're now heading into an aging global
population but certainly in the united
states but china supposedly is much
worse
um
where you got a growing number of
consumers who are expecting to have
things done for them and they don't they
don't have to pull on the ore anymore
they were retired
and
and so you're going to have demand for
goods and services and and a smaller
number to provide them that's a highly
inflationary setup
so whatever your model is going forward
i think it better deal with that problem
and
um the other thing inflation does is it
it shifts
money into the hands of the rich
because because because financialization
certainly doesn't help joe six-pack this
too will shall pass right
yeah but it's
but you know i
you know the depression was only 10
years i i argued the depression's 15.
um
i got an argument with a stanford
economist who said no
no you're wrong about that i said that
you know
low consumption during world war ii blah
blah blah and he said no the
the gdp during world war ii went up 15
something like that
and and after about 10 years i i took
them on in writing i said no
your gdp number is wrong because gdp
should include depreciation of assets
so if you crank out
a drill
you could get 10 years out of that drill
if you go to the movies you get two
hours out of that movie so they just
they're not equivalent contributors to
gdp
um
and uh
and world war two's gdp might have been
rocking but we were making battleships
and bombs and planes and stuff like that
and the depreciation rate on those was
measured in in very short time scales
now what we did do during world war ii
is we
we
made great progress towards improving
mass production so we took what henry
ford did and we put it on steroids and
so that was the uh
was what world war ii left us with was a
highly functional economy in a world
filled with unfunctional economies and
so so we were wealthy at the end of
world war ii but but
but but world war ii was i think the
blow off of the depression but it passed
to say okay so this too shall pass
but people suffered
right
world war ii passed but people suffered
the civil war passed but people suffered
and so
you know if you went and stomped on an
ant hill in your backyard you stop on it
all goddamn day and the next day you'd
go out there and there she'll be an
anthill where
but there'd be a lot of dead ants too
i don't want to be one of those right
and you think that's basically what uh
what is likely to happen here is that uh
this too shall pass but there'll be a
lot of suffering uh for various groups
in between now and then
that's right that's right i mean
depression
unemployment was 25
i mean there were parents giving away
their kids they were
it was an awful time for some people
and you just don't want to be that
person so you have to prepare not to be
that person somehow